well let me ask you just to stick on
artificial intelligence for a second do
you have worries about existential
threats from AI or extension tests from
other technologies like nuclear weapons
that could potentially destroy life on
Earth or damage it to a very significant
degree yeah of course I do
especially the weapons that we create
there's all kinds of famous ways to
think about this and one is that Wow
what if we don't see advanced alien
civilizations because of the danger of
Technology what if we reach a point and
I think there's a channel-body to cheese
I wish I remember the name of the
channel but he delves into this this
kind of limit of maybe once you discover
radioactivity and its power you've
reached this important hurdle and the
reason that the skies are so empty is
that no one's ever like managed to
survive as a civilization once they have
that destructive power and when it comes
to AI I'm not really very worried
because I think that there are plenty of
other people that are already worried
enough and oftentimes these worries are
just they just get in the way of
progress and they're there questions
that we should address later and you
know I I think I talked about this in my
interview with the self-driving
autonomous vehicle guy as I think it was
a bonus scene from the trolley problem
episode and I'm like wow what should a
car do if like this really weird
contrived scenario happens where it has
to like swerve and like save the driver
but kill a kid and he's like well you
know what would a human do and if we
resist technological progress because
we're worried about all of these little
issues then it gets in the way and we
shouldn't avoid those problems but we
shouldn't allow them to be stumbling
blocks to advancement so the you know
folks like Sam Harris or musk are saying
that we're not worried enough so worried
should not paralyze tech naw
progress but we're sort of marching
technology's marching forward without
the key scientists the developing and
technology worrying about the overnight
having some effects that would be very
detrimental to society so the push back
on your thought of the idea that there's
enough people worrying about it Elon
Musk says there's not enough people
worrying about it I think that's the
kind of balances you know it's like
folks who who really focus on nuclear
deterrence are saying there's not enough
people worried about nuclear deterrence
right so it's an interesting question of
what is a good threshold of people to
worry about these and if it's too many
people that are worried you're right
it'll be like the the press would over
report on it and there'll be
technological halt technology progress
it's not enough then we can march
straight ahead into that abyss that
human beings might be destined for with
the progress of technology yeah I don't
know what the right balance is of how
many people should be worried and how
worried should they be but we're always
worried about new technology you know we
know that Plato was worried about the
written word he's like we shouldn't
teach people to write because then they
won't use their minds to remember things
there there have been concerns over
technology and its advancement since the
beginning of recorded history and so you
know I think however these conversations
are really important to have because
again we learn a lot about ourselves if
we're really scared of some kind of AI
like coming into being that is conscious
or whatever and and can self-replicate
we already do that every day it's called
humans being born they're not artificial
they're they're they're humans but
they're intelligent and I don't want to
live in a world where we're worried
about babies being born because what if
they become evil right
what if they become mean people what if
they what if they're thieves maybe we
should just like what not have babies
born like maybe we shouldn't create AI
it's like you know we will want to have
safeguards in place yeah in the same way
that we know
look a kid could be born that becomes
some kind of evil person but we have
loss right and it's possible that with
advantage Annette --ax in general be
able to you know it's a scary thought to
say that you know the this my child
if born would be would have an 83%
chance of being a psychopath right like
being able to if it's something genetic
if there's some sort of and what to use
that information what to do with that
information is a difficult ethical yeah
I'd like to find an answer that isn't
well let's not have them live you know
I'd like to find an answer that is well
all human life is worthy and if you have
an 83% chance of becoming a psychopath
well you still deserve dignity yeah and
you still deserve to be treated well and
a you still have rights
at least at this part of the world at
least in America there's a respect for
individual life in that way that's well
to me but again I'm in this bubble is a
beautiful thing but there's other
cultures or individual human life is not
that important that we're a society so I
was born in Soviet Union where the
strength of nation and society together
is more important than the any one
particular individual so it's an
interesting also notion the stories we
tell ourselves I like the one where
individuals matter but it's unclear that
that was what the future holds well yeah
and I mean let me even throw this out
like what is artificial intelligence how
can it be artificial I really think that
we get pretty obsessed and stuck on the
idea that there is some thing that is a
wild human a pure human organism without
technology but I don't think that's a
real thing I think that humans and human
technology are one organism look at my
glasses okay if an alien came down and
saw me would they necessarily know that
this is an invention that I don't grow
these organically from my body they
wouldn't know that
away and the written word and spoons and
cups these are all pieces of technology
we are not alone as an organism and so
the technology we create whether it be
video games or artificial intelligence
that can self-replicate and hate us it's
actually all the same organism I when
you're in a car where do you end in the
car begin it seems like a really easy
question to answer but the more you
think about it the more you realize wow
we are in this symbiotic relationship
with our inventions and there are plenty
of people who are worried about it and
there should be but it's it's inevitable
and I think the even just us think of
ourselves as individual intelligences
maybe silly notion because you know it's
much better to think of the entirety of
human civilization living all living
organs on earth as a single living
organism right as a single intelligent
creature because you're right
everything's intertwined everything is
deeply connected
you